for everyone and no matter where you are
Allah will find you I was a missionary I
when I'm working with this trips with
the church I spoke in the church I sing
in the church I was in Bible cuisine I
did everything I could in the church and
one day God told me a lot told me
there's something about and you have to
do something I have a plan for you I
could never figure out what it was until
the one day I picked up fraud and felt
peace and realized that the way that I
was raised the way that I was going was
the way that Allah and upon Allah I
became Muslim 19 years ago and it it's
an amazing amazing life ever since you
are actually a missionary I went to
Colorado Springs Colorado and we
build broken-down homes from storms and
witness and sing to the people and hand
out food we worked at soup kitchens and
how about what was the main thing about
Islam that draw drew you to it that was
different was we always spoke about
Jesus was saying about Jesus every
sermon was about Jesus and God was
missing from everything and I thought
where is God in all of this was the one
who came who made everything so why
aren't we singing of him why are we
talking about heaven so when I started
reading and seen all of the things about
Allah and everyone is worshiping Allah
and those of my times prayer just
focusing on Allah it meant so much to me
and I realized that a man cannot be a
God he cannot he wasn't there yet he was
a messenger
and you did amazing amazing things but
he was not the Son of God and he did it
is not through him that I'm gonna get
do you still love Jesus
how could you not block the messenger
that Allah sent and shown all the people
at that time
the right way to live and just becomes
again a little bit construed along the
way it doesn't mean he wasn't a prophet
he wasn't a messenger he came to teach
and show the people at that time but
he's still relevant
you know a lot since everyone when
they're supposed to be said and I still
love Jesus I just realized he's not some
God he's not my Savior he's not the one
who's going to get me to jump
[Music]
when people hear this word Allah it's
really strange for them
can you define when you say Allah what
do you mean so a lot is God it's just
another way of saying God it's how it
said in Arabic but it is God the one god
there's one dog
there's not many gods there people can
put names on everything I mean he is the
he is the one who made us all who
created us and so it is nothing
different it's not God and and Allah is
two different people or two different
two different gods one can you just
briefly talk about the hijab admit that
Jesus is a mother wear what you're
wearing this hijab I mean we're using
any picture of Mary ended up in the job
even in the Catholic Church the picture
of mother Mary is India job she's not
without the start with her hair uncover
and why wouldn't you if you're following
her and other religions and everything
but so is the job so different because
your hustle I mean you should recognize
that for people who think that Islam is
synonymous with terrorism and violence
what do you say it's so far from the
truth because Islam does not even allow
you you should be even break a branch of
the tree
you don't work one another it is said to
be kind you have to love
that's what Allah is Allah is love you
cannot harm one another it says that if
you hurt one person one of mankind not
one Muslim any one of mankind it is as
though you have hurt everyone
so but there is no such thing eaters
they in Islam people stay in their way
and what they may think but that is not
last suggestions for anybody who's
looking into Islam but they're kind of
scared like what their family or the
pressure from society what advice do you
give to them how did you overcome that
it isn't always easy because who doesn't
agree or who doesn't know anything about
fun is scary all they've heard is what
they purr on TV and you have to just
a good must have good support good
community there's so many out there game
piece does a really great job all the
different mustards that you're involved
in make sure that you have backup in
community and there's so much love and
care that is surrounding you and don't
give up there's hope
thank you so much
you